I'll tell you what man you know it's
really really funny when I did this this
they call it heat training hostile
environment action or something I know
it's called but it's called like a heat
course go and some of the people that
were there like was like a weather guy
there now there's a reason why a weather
guy will be at the hostile environment
training course because hurricanes it
wasn't just about yeah that makes um you
know getting kidnapped cuz they have to
go stand on the beach while it's behind
them and there I'm here reporting is
really an it's like the lowest tier yeah
and I swear this guy was so arrogant
yeah oh the news reporter he's a weather
got surprising and I'm sitting there
like listen this guy talked and he's
like yeah there's a bunch of women we're
like sitting at a table it was like
lunch he's so tough I and he's like
listen he's not gonna do you know like
when you're dealing with this stuff and
I'm just like
tell me weatherman tell me more about
how you respond to when the terrorists
are kidnapping you
willy wonka and then I was like I shook
my head and I was just like I started
talking about what actually happens and
he's like you think you know how this
stuff goes goes on and I was like dude I
was like first of all everybody has a
different reaction you don't know you've
never been in situations and you have I
was like yes actually I have I swear it
was a really funny thing that happened
with this training they put us in this
scenario where we are driving in SUV's
to go meet with you know like a terror
leader or something it's all it's all
you know fictional okay and then the
cars get stopped at a fake checkpoint
and the guys have a bunch of random
weapons and they start yelling and then
our driver who is part of the training
he's supposed to be a local a fixer it's
the local hotels you he says yeah okay
oh it's a government checkpoint then
when everyone got of the vehicles and so
okay we all get out they make us all
land our stomachs all of the women get
brought to a to a shed where we then
hear although men screaming and the guy
and the guys with the guns are all
laughing saying like there are women now
and stuff like that and then they start
going around saying give us all your
valuables and so then I they went up and
the guy was like in your wall and I said
here you go and they took to walk away
and I was like oh a sir you forgot my
watch and he was like oh yeah I did
forget your watch and he takes my watch
the funny thing about it was the watch
was a GPS tracker
so after was oh it was over we went back
to the main area
and the guy someone asked so that the
trainer guy was like sometimes these
things happen you know you'll get
stopped you'll notice that all the guys
had different weapons which means
they're likely not government because I
have standard-issue mm-hmm these things
got to pay attention to but if you're
being stopped by a group of armed
individuals and how much you can do and
someone said what about the women who
are kidnapped and clearly being abused
and he goes they're gone you know
sometimes there's nothing you can do
about it
and I and afterwards one of the guys was
there and I said I was gonna let you go
you guys were wrong about that and he
was like oh yeah what do you mean and I
said well remember when I said my watch
like yeah I'm like that watch is a GPS
tracker as soon as as soon as you let us
go I call the State Department told them
how to find it and he went really and I
was like this was this was this was back
when smart watches weren't a thing okay
so it was a 4g watch that looked like a
regular watch got him got him boom and
so I told him I was like listen man I
was like in this in the stuff that I've
done with my buddies who actually work
in like info sack and actual OPSEC stuff
we've gone through contingencies for how
to deal with legit top-tier full you
know full tech warfare to the best of
our civilian understanding one of the
things was like they actually said to
charge your GPS and bring it with you
and I was like no no no no Marie Colvin
was a conflict journalist and what we
understand is that the the the Assad
regime was tracking her Sat phone found
out where she was and that started
shelling the building oh geez so you
don't want to have an active GPS signal
they can track and figure out where you
are satellite link okay so what we did
was when we when my buddy went we
brought we gave him a two-way satellite
communicator to make sure he had one you
know why you leave it off and then once
you're compromised you turn it on and
throw it down a hill and run the other
direction you buy yourself some time
they know where you are already
then they'll chase after the dummy
signal okay so this is the kind of stuff
they don't teach you but you know I'm
interested anyway I digress that was a
fun story I love that hello it's someone
just went Tim pools the Jason Bourne on
budget I'm just good common no not even
I would never consider myself to be an
expert and or within reason but what I
sell people like when this guy's
mouthing off about how he's like here's
what you go to do and here's I'm like
listen anybody who tells you they can
guarantee you security and safety is
lying you anybody's gonna tell you
here's definitively what you do is lying
to you and I said we were talking
specifically about what to do in the
event of a kidnapping and I said there
so that we did this mock scenario where
we we're going to interview it's all
basically saying that you're no
interview you know this is this leader
we pulled to the building and I'm I'm on
a hair-trigger already because I know I
know the game and so they say okay
everybody go to the car as we're going
inside and then the guy in front of me
was a was a he just out of the Marines
so he was getting a job in security for
Catholic security contractor this guy's
a Marine yeah and all of a sudden we
hear someone yell and we pop our doors
and just both run full speed slightly
zigzagging down through dead ground nice
we know what we were doing yeah and then
all of a sudden week week we get like
100 yards out we duck behind some trees
and we hear you guys are dead you're
dead come back and we looked at you on
started laughing or not we got we got
really not and so we walked back and one
of the training guys like you guys died
and we were laughing we're like okay
sure like no we we hit dead Grantley so
dead ground is when the people you can't
shoot felt like a hillside okay once you
clear a certain amount of space
someone's standing up on the hill can't
shoot through the hill right they have
to run to the edge and then try and
shoot down so we hit we went straight
for dead ground and then we were we were
gone but they told us to come back and
he goes well if you want to do the
training exercise well pretend like
you're not dead and we're like alright
fine whatever
and so then they literally told us do
whatever you can to do whatever you want
to do you're being kidnapped do whatever
you want get out of it figure it out and
I'm like you got a buddy
and so I I passed out and fake threw up
and they started freaking out and
cancelled the event they're like all
right everybody sucks like buddy buddy
are you all right and I was like yeah
I'm totally fine and they're like it
whatever you want what and I was like I
was faking being sick and they went oh
why
and I was like to make it a burden on
the kidnappers to decide whether to take
me or leave me and they were like oh
okay stand back up get back in line
and I'm like so you fooled them twice
you
the first time they're like ma'am I
should have been we shouldn't have at
least we could have like told them to do
whatever they want and that before they
did what they did and then we would have
told them they were dead
so but this is the that you fooled them
twice this is what precipitated the guy
who's talking about you know him knowing
what he was doing and I was explaining
why I ran in the first place okay and
why I feigned being sick and I said I
can't tell you this would work because
you don't necessarily know the mentality
of the people who are trying to kidnap
you yeah that's good I can tell you my
logic the first is if they're gonna
kidnap you now as an American you're
actually likely to get rescued Americans
don't the American government does not
negotiate and they do not pay ransoms so
it's it's actually in many circumstances
kidnappers will avoid Americans at all
costs interesting a lot of these poor
guys in these countries when they kidnap
somebody they're thinking about can we
get cash quick what happens if you
kidnap someone who's Spanish or German
those government's pay out right away
boom really oh yeah so true yup and
because of this they're sought-after if
you're an American you know what
Americans deliver when you kidnap an
American payload a helicopter commando
raid kicking your door in and killing
you and your family so it's not not all
the time but the American government is
dead serious about you're not gonna pay
and we're gonna f you up yeah so that's
the goal the goal is to deter and so
that's actually what they advise they
advise to capitulate do whatever your
captors want because in all likelihood
the American government's gonna come in
guns a-blazing just be like just tell
them you're American but what American
but there's also up next however yeah at
this time we're talking about the
expansion of some certain factions in
the Middle East that glorify the
execution of journalists on purpose yeah
that's true and so you know what I was
basically saying to people is like
listen live on your feet die on your
knees I can run and if these guys are
using long guns they can be extremely
accurate with low training and hey men
maybe maybe they'll waste the bullet on
you maybe they'll say it's not worth it
we've already got 15 other people let
them go that when they brought me back
and I pretended being sick
people were like yeah but then they'll
just kill you I'm like why maybe what do
you think they're thinking are they
thinking this person's having a panic
attack they're sick I don't want to deal
with it I don't want to get sick either
or care
I don't want to carry them I don't want
to get sick I don't want to deal with it
maybe they'll kill you maybe they won't
maybe they're regardless not everyone
has a Lydia to carry your burden right
so it I said listen no one's gonna tell
you and in fact the people training
specifically said you can't predict
these things but we can we can maximize
your opportunity by giving me preparing
you to the best of our abilities and so
I said my instinct would always be run
come run don't give in don't bow if they
catch you they catch you but run and if
you have to passively resist do so in a
proper way
you don't antagonize them you just
become a burden that they don't want to
deal with yeah it's not perfect many
people who have survived have just done
whatever they're told and just waited
that for a couple years
that's if that may that may work and
that's what a lot of people have done
it's hard to know we've also seen people
get their heads chopped off so you
better you better decide based on the
current circumstances is if it was a 1%
chance they're gonna film you being on
fire I had one percent chance one
percent chance that's the same as like
it was a 1% chance something it happened
would you take the at the raht the odds
so for me I'm kind of like man I'd
rather run I'd rather run than put a
ball in my back
notice I know I tried I'm not gonna bend
the need anybody and if they catch me
you know what then I lost but when they
made me faint being sick I'm like at
least at this point I can be annoying
passively you don't want the person to
get mad at you thinking you're doing it
on purpose but it's it's you know it's
reasonable to think that if someone got
kidnapped they'd be panicking shaking
and getting sick and then you'd be like
I don't want to deal with this you know
I mean yeah what are they gonna now if
they're trying to get a ransom from you
or Amit or you know you might it might
be worth the vomit they might be like
I'm going for a million bucks dude you
can barf all you want I'll take you but
yeah these tried something I guess
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you